i think monique you suggested at an
earlier meeting we asked them to
come and grant us grunt edge grants
grants here to speak on behalf of
rangiora beautiful
greg miller couldn't make it so grant if
you just want to come up
and welcome
welcome to you so it's good to have you
here
as you all know grant there's another
hat at times and that is
a council of free cans but he's here on
behalf of
keeper angela beautiful so thanks mr
chairman
councillors board members um yeah greg
couldn't make it today
um so i've the two things that i'm
wanting to cover today
are sort of related to flexton road
upgrade both a section of the roadworks
themselves based on a submission that we
made
in january to two council staff
and also just to finish on some comment
on the flexton ponds
that we've been working on as well
i've got a little powerpoint up up there
which
maybe i'll just quickly run through that
so could you just explain
um i was unaware you were talking about
frackstone road oh
okay uh that you weren't down to talk
about that you were here to talk about
the
partnership and beautification of the
streetscapes
if you wish to make a passing reference
but we don't want you to get into the
issue because you haven't asked
permission to talk to the facts and
really oh
sorry okay yeah oh okay well that makes
passing reference i suggest right okay
so in passing reference to um that
road treatment um the
keep renewal beautiful group um
had made some submissions uh to the
long-term plan way back in 2018
and with the idea that we would
we had supported
beautification tree planting of some of
our significant streets
and in terms of
plexton road for example
our submission of that time was based on
rangiora town centre 2020
um strategy which had
aimed at providing for better approaches
and entry points into the town centre
to enhance key transport corridors
so with reference to
that road on the screen
we felt that that was a really important
access
into the town and we had made a
submission on that
and we're really wanting to make sure
that in that particular
example for for for
tree planting for example to make sure
that as many trees and plantings can
take place
especially on the waterways side
of that of that stretch of road
it's quite variable it's nice in places
and on the other side of the road it's a
bit
need a bit more attention
so you see on on the um on that side of
the road that where the
most of the industry stuff is um the
roadway
varies and the quality of it is is quite
poor and people do different things to
it so
those sorts of things really need to be
looked at in terms of the corridor
approach
how can how can we beautify the
corridors a bit better
yeah my my submission to you today
really mr chairman was
specifically on flexton road but the
principles of that reply to everything
really
um we had commented and we were sort of
hoping that we could get
better treatment here that's the council
proposal on the top
side um and some indication of
of the swale on with it with a cycle
pedestrian
facility as well
if we go to the next uh slide
um this is the existing situation on
flexton road
we have um the waterway
and some planting on the waterway grass
boom which is a bit
eaten eaten back and with an unsealed
berm
two-way carriageway and then we have
variable parking arrangements and
footpath arrangements on the other side
so that's the existing situation across
a cross section of around about 23
meters
three meters of which is the the actual
waterway part
we had suggested um a really different
approach
a creative approach and i think that in
terms of your
roadway design ivory street at the
moment
i'm really really pleased and i think
that council should be
really happy i think with its treatment
of ivory street where where there's
really um some definition of car park
bays
and planting which is what we're sort of
showing up here
um and that will all add to an important
route through the town
but this particular council's proposal
has a central
flush median but in my experience as a
as a designer of of roads from time to
time
we can be more creative with the way we
prepare our cross sections
and so i'm suggesting that there's
there's opportunities
that that have perhaps could be taken up
and whether it's too late i don't know
but
certainly if there's ability in the
cross section to tweak a few things here
and there that would be fantastic just
to get some more planting
um i'll just i'll keep going um jones
uh so you've got um so that's a
cross-section
of um a variable with and and we were
just suggesting that um
for me i i don't see the need for for a
flash medium but that council's already
made that decision
and in which case it is looking at can
we tweak some of this
cross-section um on the sides
and perhaps even in the middle to claw
back a little bit more to give more
to the waterway because we have a new
national policy statement
on tamannaah otawai which gives priority
to water
and even though it's acting as a drain
it is still
fed of my understanding from a natural
spring
and and so just looking at those little
issues to give a little bit more back
there's a road i designed a concept for
in craig road near the university quite
a few years ago same carriageway with
as we have here in flaxton road
it has some planting in the center of
the road
it's a minor arterial has 20 000
vehicles per day
and it just has some really interesting
uh combinations
of the way to treat cyclists pedestrians
carriageway and planting so that's the
sort of thing
and that was part of a part of my
personal submission to the council
trying to get some creative response
on a because really wide carriageways
without any planting
just become horrible gray situations and
in our industrial
area leading up to um through flexton
road it is not a pretty place
and we need to do better
um i so that's flexton road
the other the other issue which monique
has been involved with too as part of
our group
is that we were hoping to get and i
think um
mr chairman you were involved with a
meeting that we had a while back
trying to get a link in this current
construction process
across here to get into this pond
environment
so that it becomes an attractive public
open space
and so that's missing off the current um
design drawings and it's really
important i think to
when we've got a huge asset here
wildlife
it's a wetland area and it's also
potentially a really nice way to get to
the future development that's
this facility that's going to go on down
here
and we have a benefactor who's prepared
to donate a sum of money
and all we need here is a little uh very
low-key
bridge to cross through the soil and and
we then complete a really good linkage
for the community
that's the pond and so we're talking
about somehow getting a link to this
point through here
at this corner by the cafe which will
then enable people to
travel along the top of the embankment
and to get into this area by fernside
road and
in the big facility that's going across
here
and last week we marked out their trees
with
staff and we're looking at doing a
community planting project in a couple
of weeks time
around the outside we found that we
can't plant anything in these areas here
because that's
there's a liner apparently so but anyway
it's it's uh
it's all part of this beautification
process and that will add to the entry
to the town as well
so um those really the message i'm
trying to say
is see if we get that linkage
and going forward anything that we can
do from flaxton road to kind of
make it a little bit greener but i think
in terms of your
traffic planning transportation planning
that
we really um yeah look at those amenity
values
a lot better but there are some good
things happening
thanks thank thank you i understood at
that meeting
that yes we had a benefactor that was
going to provide the trees
i i thought the rest was going to be
faint accompli from
what the staff commented that they were
was i wrong
no i yeah i thought that there was sort
of a move to get that
that link is you know incorporated but
if it's
not too late yes because it's
a good exercise any questions of grant
jones
um thank you grant love your enthusiasm
but
i think you need to know that the
blackstone road plans have slightly
changed
their concept plans the the cycleway and
the walkway now is on the east side and
not the west side because of
some concerns about erosion of the
not the ditch or the the waterway that's
there
so so the plans are have been adjusted
and changed that have
that are underway at the moment so um i
think that
um you might need to look at
changed arrangements that might be
happening
the final arrangement um and also that i
think we have to keep in mind that
uh there's a roundabout going off inside
road
um on to flexton road so
we maybe need to consider
um just halting final
beautification decisions until
that's all underway all that that is um
that is completed because it might alter
things to slowly
can i say that we we've we've already
run this past
your traffic engineers and in terms of
sight lines and things like that there
was there's no issues
and and in terms of the roundabout
that's been considered
um so but i mean a tree can come out of
it if in the end it has to but no those
those issues have been considered um i
would be interested to
see i certainly haven't received any
information since mid-july
from council staff that there's been
some major change to
not not allowing for um a
joint cycle footpath on the waterway
side
um i know there is a footpath on the
other side as well
but i yeah so i'd be interested to to
uh just it's just a recent um
recent thing that's been brought to
council um for consideration because
of of because of um
of um the bank embankment
on that western side not being sound
and so um the geotext so um they're
looking we're looking very seriously
at the subway walkway being on the east
side as opposed to the west side so that
may change things it might change
oh well that may actually provide a
facility for some um
better improvement on the on the stream
side yeah which
i don't know who's first murray can you
turn that off yeah please
probably a couple there that a lot of
that vaccine road comes up tonight on uh
can you speak into maybe
that flexing road thing comes up tonight
a wee bit on the uh
project in that center but a road i
think that's
designed more for a um a runoff for the
trucks so they can turn into places so
trees and don probably
would better consume or deny that
scenario so trees may not be
um a nice place from that center because
we're
your um cleans probably a lot more cars
we're going to have
overworked tracks and even on that road
as well so we've got to be very
cautious but yes um what i was
going to talk about is just slipped out
of my
head um oh yeah
when you're beautiful they started on
the project on the railway lines and
in ranger to the center and all of a
sudden it's come to a bit of a halt for
the last few years
um do you know if rangiora beautiful is
going to finish the project there which
has been started about 15 years
ago i think from time to time there's
there's um
some maintenance work that we do on that
but i think it's because of the
rail corridor and yeah it's
it's it needs more professional
management i suspect along the rail
corridor just you know they have scenes
for doing things north some
yeah i think i think vandalism and all
that sort of stuff but
you know it's a fairly um it's an
enthusiastic group and we sometimes get
engaged
in various projects with lions and
rotary and people like that but um
it's an aging so no plans to finish no
plans to finish there's there's other
issues uh plans that we've got on the
books
um should should you look at finishing
jobs before you start new ones
well i don't know whether that was a
suggestion it's always
starting something that's nice whether
others can i can take
take it over i don't know murray here
the question
no i was going to comment on and support
what jones said i'd actually had an
exchange of emails
with don young over the last few days
because
i was concerned about the fact that if
the drain was
with recently not debating the issue
we're asking questions
mr edge okay that's all right okay
kirsten thank you grant for your um
presentation and excited to hear that
you're going to do something near soda
cafe because it's a really lovely place
and just wondered because you're here
could you just tell us a little bit more
about the key projects the group
is planning for this year's because we
haven't really heard a lot from you for
a while no no we're sort of conscious of
that really
it's always good communication so it's a
pond the pond project is is our primary
one at the moment for this season
because
some deciduous trees need to be in the
ground in the next couple of months at
the latest
we also had some trees for
river view road um by the hospital i
think there's about six
six trees to go in there just as an
infill and replacements for some
street trees that have been lost um
we've also been
working with the hub the hospital
site which we did a few years ago so
there's some follow-up planting for that
and we will probably get back into
looking at milton ave but it would
probably be
in the context of a broader picture
of um what's going on there
the board's looking at that too at the
moment so we'll undoubtedly
talk to you later about this yes
so you've got a cleanup event coming up
this weekend yes there's a cleanup event
this weekend yeah so some
some members are always getting
enthusiastic about that too so
yeah i think there's some other projects
too we've we have got some stuff in the
in the pipeline uh passiondale
uh walkway was something that we we
maybe try to add on
um but just doing a little bit at a time
really
um when you talk about the deciduous
trees at the pond
um wouldn't autumn also be a really good
time to put them in if it ever had to be
not this spring but
autumn would also work usually winter
winter
time or the plants are been growing on
in pots so they can
the time frame is a little bit better
for those but usually deciduous trees if
they're being rooted anyways
it's usually winter yeah so no further
questions grant thank you very much for
coming along we appreciate the work that
keep
bringing your beautiful has done over
the years and is still doing so
thank you right rachel thornton our
community development facilitator is
going to
explain her role so welcome rachel
good evening everybody thank you for
your invitation to come and introduce
myself
um is this working right yes no it's
funny
my name's rachel and i am the new
community development facilitator
i'm here at the council and
i guess i'll just give you a wee bit of
my background if that's all right and
that will help
inform maybe some questions or my role
i actually started my journey in
community development and social justice
and the hope community trust i helped
set that up post earthquake
and then i since subsequently i've
always lived in
in rangora in the waimak um subsequently
i've worked
internationally and nationally in
various charities
and then i was doing some consulting
because i'm particularly passionate
about sustainability
and some of the interfaces between
charities and business and
how things can be done well to support
the community
and it's well-being and
yeah and so then i saw the job
advertised and decided it was time to
come back to
our community and hopefully invest a
whole lot of skills and
experience that i've got from my
previous work
and so i started just after
the covet event and have literally hit
the ground running
with various projects and things my role
was
officially vibrant communities community
development facilitator
however because of covert they've been a
few projects that have come up quite
quickly that need
attention so yeah i'm
fairly busy at the moment but very much
enjoying it
yeah so happy to answer any questions
any questions
all right well thank you very thank you
very much
nice to meet you right thank you
all right item 6.1
flexton road upgrade pages 17
to 33. don
welcome
and fraser is it that's correct yeah
right um
so the utilities and writing committee
approved the current scheme design for
the flex and road upgrade project
and authorized proceeding to the
detailed design stage at the 19th of may
meeting since approval to proceed with
the scheme design council staff have
been working to develop the design
but unfortunately during the design
development stage an embankment
stability risk was realized
that has the potential to significantly
impact the project budget
so ultimately we have two options the
first option is to maintain the current
scheme design
and address the bank stability issues
within the design
i.e engineer our way out of the problem
or option two
relocate the shared path to the eastern
side
of flaxton road so the purpose of this
report is to
first of all explain why the scheme
design that was approved
by the utilities and roading committee
and that may meeting
is now expected to significantly exceed
the total budget available
secondly present the updated cost
estimate and recommend an alternative
alternative scheme design based on the
shared path on the eastern side of
flaxstone road
between southwood road and kingsford
smith drive should note that a one and a
half metre wide
footpath is proposed as a link between
kingsford smith and the resource
recovery center on the western side of
flaxstone road
and third and finally obtain your your
approval or your wrangler ashley
community wars endorsement sorry
for the recommended scheme design for
the flax and road upgrade works as being
suitable for consultation
subject to a satisfactory safety order
outcome and approval by council
and i should note that council have now
approved the design
thank you i know the recommendations
because this is
coming straight from the utilities and
writing committee and decisions
have been made that don i think the
recommendations if you just have a look
at
d should that not now read that the
council has considered rather than will
and that and the outcome
was provided to the borders tonight's
meeting i think we need to change that
so do you wish to add anything
we um just i suppose a little bit
further there we we have been just
working over the last week or so and
preparing the information
in anticipation of your uh endorsement
today
so we have arranged for the
uh for dropping meetings which
will be next wednesday next wednesday at
7 30 in the morning until
nine and another one in the afternoon
from four
to 5 30 and
we will be at the cafe
at the soda cafe in the meantime the
letters
and flyers will be going out to all of
the businesses
in the next day or so uh inviting them
firstly either to comment
or to come along and talk with us
about the potential change
in addition to that we would note i
think just give a little bit of an
update here that
we certainly have been listening to the
points
made by mr edge as a submitter
and we believe i think as was commented
at the table here that
this change would in fact uh open up
more opportunities for the types of
improvements
and beautification that is being
suggested
we haven't got very much of it included
in our plans to date
but we certainly do have uh some stream
beautification and some
trees etc allowed for in our design
but i've just arranged with mr edge that
we will be in touch with each other in
the next week or so
and ensure that as part of our firstly
our discussion with the
well yes as part of our discussion with
the businesses we will also engage with
them by the time you see a report back
we'll be able to further update you on
on opportunities
you're well aware from previous reports
that we are very tight on budget
and so we won't be able to undertake to
do an awful lot extra
but we certainly will look at
opportunities
to either include things or to allow for
things to be included in the future
with regard to the linkage path
that was also referred to by mr edge
we are currently doing some
investigation about how that might be
best achieved
and there will be a little bit of a
round of
internal conversation which will
probably make its way back
as well with that report to you about
what we could or couldn't do there again
there's a budgetary issue there we don't
have budget for that link
it would need to come from a separate
budget and that will be part of the
conversation we will have internally
uh to advise you of of options relating
to that
but we're certainly mindful that
completing that link to that
uh stormwater area would be really
beneficial
and there are some big advantages
including it in the current
contract so we're mindful of the
advantages of that it'll just be
[Music]
you're very enlightened down there
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you mr chair we're happy to take
questions i i i should have welcomed
his worship the mayor down the back too
welcome dan right
quick questions of don jones
subsequent to our meeting the other day
i traveled down
flexton road and looking at the eastern
side
now with the proposed cycleway pathway
on the eastern side as opposed to the
western side i noticed there
are huge new power poles directly in the
path
of the present pathway is that going to
be an issue
in short yes it will be a reduced
function
facility it is likely that we've
identified three locations in which we
will need to
effectively split the path around the
concrete poles
for all other locations we will i think
have to compromise on the shared path
width and it's likely that we can
squeeze a 2.3 meter wide path in from
the face of the curb to the inside edge
of the power pole
the plans when if when you do get the
opportunity to see them in some detail
you'll notice that
the the curbing moves in and out on that
western side
eastern side sorry uh
where it is on line at the moment at
times
we will be replacing that and bringing
it out into the carriageway
to go around obstacles that are there
and then there will be parking only in
those areas
that remain so we will be achieving a
little bit of what mr edge said in ivory
street
but in a much larger scale there will be
build-outs
we haven't given much thought to
landscaping opportunities in those
build-outs
obviously they are mainly happening
around power poles so the
large tree opportunity is pretty limited
but there still could be shrubs and
and and landscaping of some nature which
happened in those build-out areas
which are being built for other purposes
to get us around
obstacles do you talk to green space
about those issues
yes green space are part of our
competition and subsequent to that
then if the power poles are there will
they be lit
at night so people will be able to see
they highlighted those power poles if
they're traveling at night
yes the current design does include an
allowance for street lighting so
that will be fully lit when members are
asking questions or speaking could you
bend your microphone so you talk into
them it's not easy to hear
down the back i think when you're not
looking at them
questions morris
just just on the drain side of it you
said you could actually engineer your
way
out of it no doubt at a cost just
quickly
how would you do that because it's sort
of quite a compromise to
shift away from that to the power poles
being that
i mean i understand it was geotech that
their report
claimed that it could subside in an
earthquake but to be pretty nice the
power pole could probably
fall on your head in an earthquake too
so
so we looked at various options piping
retaining structures and just localized
treatment along the
embankment face itself um
the issue is really to do with the
proximity of the of the curb
to the drain the further back further
away you retreat from that drain the
lower the risk of any
slope stability issues so with the
current
the existing design we were encroaching
into that zone of influence
which effectively meant that the
likelihood or the probability of
encountering some slope stability issues
within the next
four years were reasonably high and that
was an exciting
risk that council were just not prepared
to take
[Music]
right um
so further to
fraser's point there we specifically
requested i suppose a risk-based
assessment to give us some
good feedback and to explain
fraser's point a bit it was indicating
that it was a four-year return period
that would potentially uh
cause damage to our new infrastructure
and we felt that was an unreasonable
risk that if we
built curbs and footpaths and things and
they were getting damaged and needing
repair every
four years that would not be a good
outcome for us
uh and it was based on a probability
type thing like uh
like fraser said with the slopes and the
further we went back the better slope we
had
and therefore the lower risk we had but
we found we were just squeezing
ourselves up too far by trying to move
to give that reasonable distance we were
compromising in
other areas like the width of the road
or
the remaining width of the footpath so
all things told yes we could have
engineered our way out of that we had an
estimate
done for that which was in the close to
a million dollars for
additional uh stability works along
there
and that was presented as one of the
options but
fairly quickly rejected
further questions duncan
could somebody just explain to me that
the covert 19 procurement panel
and and its role in is there any
indication at this stage
uh is the tendering market tighter or is
it
people starting to take advantage of
some of the money that's available
as far as pricing goes
the the covered panel was set up at a
staff
management level through levels
three and four or four and three and
its intention was to ensure that council
didn't engage
in contracts where there was a
reasonable risk
of returning back up through the levels
and therefore potentially incurring
significant
uh disestablishment and establishment
costs on a repeated basis
and so it was more established as a risk
mitigation
to ensure that staff weren't
individually
going out to the marketplace earlier
than the organization
was happy with that
covert committee has has virtually
become a little bit defunct over the
last month or two and really
is not part of our process at the moment
it will of course reinvigorate itself if
we move back into that
in terms of the marketplace we've just
uh received the tenders for
park and ride which were parked in ryde
rangiora and park and ride
kaiapoi and we did see
a very high level of interest we had 12
tinderists for each and the prices were
significantly below
our estimate we're expecting
however that this is a relatively well
we're not sure how long but
the the window of that may
come to an end as shovel ready projects
around the country develop and that
large
volume of work that is being released by
the government
does come to the market so there'll be
another assessment of what
the effect that has had on the market
when that
when those do come through any further
questions
just to remind you before someone moves
it that d
will read that the council has
considered
and and the outcome
will be provided at tonight's meeting
with those changes someone prepared to
move
move both paul seconded all right
do you wish to speak well i think it's a
project that's um
coming along looking good um one of my
questions was that you'd asked to um
communicate with wren you're beautiful
but you've actually beat me to the punch
line there so that was cool
and um but yeah i think we need to get
on to it
and um get the project done because it's
been a
long time coming jason do you wish to
speak nothing perfectly
so discussion
it appears to be none duncan um i i will
support the motion but
look i i i'll be the first one
to suggest you know the last one to
suggest the council should spend more
money and i i suppose i've got to say my
piece
is uh i affect i think they've
overlooked the opportunity regarding the
the piping of the drain considering the
status of water that
now has in our community and shovel
really tight projects
i can't understand why something
possibly couldn't have been done
um and you know i think that's a project
that's got perhaps a 10 or 50 year
payback i honestly believe in five years
time will regret
this but i am i do believe
that this thing just speaking very
briefly
um honestly i agree with duncan totally
i think
time will show that it was short-sighted
not to pipe that drain
i know the cost i just agree with duncan
but i'm going to support the
resolution any other speakers i would
like it recorded that i was the only
counsellor that wanted that to happen
right because
just just just to um comment on this it
has been through an incredibly thorough
process and
the the cost wasn't the only reason for
not piping the drain
in fact there's one councillor who will
tell you that the word drainage should
not be used in our vocabulary
they are waterways and that they carry
water that
has to have that goes to other areas
that is of significance to other areas
so
the way we view water i think is going
to change significantly in the next 20
years
um it's already showing in the policies
that we're getting from government
we are not going to have a choice in
that and we are going to have to enact
that policy
and so it's going to be very very
difficult to try and change
the view of water having more importance
sometimes than the businesses or people
around it
so there is a change of philosophy that
is coming from national legislation as
well
so unfortunately putting all that
together plus
the cost which was significant um this
was the decision that council made and
and i uh support exactly what was said
by the mover that we need to get on with
this
and with luck the way that waterway can
be improved to link up with the
beautiful
um stormwater area down at next to soda
cafe
and can actually become quite an amenity
feature for an entrance to our district
anyone else paul write a play
no all right i'll put it all those in
favor please say aye
the country carried item six point
sorry dot mr chicken we we will be
forwarding this information to
the your members will also be
getting forward that and you're all more
than welcome to come along
uh to hear firsthand any thoughts
next wednesday what time there's two
one in the morning and one in the
afternoon and we'll ensure that that's
included and the information that
they've afforded
thank you thank you um can i break
standing orders again mr
chair i know i did this to you last time
i just wanted to give you a wee brief
update with regard to this
the south brook pedestrian
works which have been discussed a
previous report that you approved
mentioned that there would be a report
coming back to you
and i think it's stated the october your
october meeting
since that time we've been awarded
additional money for
uh for an element called innovative
streets
uh which has a different focus
and we are thinking about how we utilize
that in dentures
and marshalls to improve the overall
space there
it has a different process for engaging
including co-design with the community
so i guess i'm sending a signal that
it's unlikely we won't be back to you
for your october meeting
that engagement with the community will
probably take
an extra month or two and it'll pro it
may even be
early in the year before we come back to
you we will still be
aiming to complete a decision-making
process
and a design this financial year which
was our original technology
not only will you be talking to the
schools where you'll be talking to
dench's road and tools road about one
weighing
one weighing and all the other options
that's correct well that's good
thanks don right thank you very much
thanks razer
right item 6.2 road names pages 34
to 43.
scott good evening
um
any um fairly straightforward
someone prepared to no question someone
prepared to move
something moved what are you moving
sarah
the recommendations you're moving
a and b
let's see okay
i i just thought looking at road this is
the name of this road isn't it to
why why that name i understand was it
local farmers
item 4.2 in the report
yeah i did so morris were you second
thing
thank you do you wish to
speak to sarah
morris
anyone anyone else there's nothing to
reply to so i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say the
country clearer carried
item 6.3 pages 44 to
52. are you dealing with that k who's
dealing with that liz
or who you go right
um as you have read the report
just explaining to you um the
process for
the represent the representation review
which will be
um hopefully in place for the 2022
election
i take it is read and the um
item c is asking for a board member
to be rangiora ashley's
representative on that working party so
um if you've got any questions i'll
happy to try and answer
are there any questions okay
all right just before i look for someone
duncan um
are you prepared to i'm only
pre-possessing we might agree with you
but are you happy to be
if nominated by the board's
representative um
i'm happy to move the recommendation and
i'll see
a point board member duncan lundy i'm
signing over there
by money i i nominated at duncan because
it's a very important very important
role that this committee plays and i've
been on it twice i
understand a wee bit of the
ramifications of it
it will help establish the formation of
local government in this district and
the ward boundaries and
maybe the number or whatever that comes
up as you read in the report
and duncan with his wide-ranging
experience both his previous counsellor
as a board member and also is in the
rural area so he understands the
importance of
the rural and the urban coming together
and that's why i nominated
duncan because i think he's well
qualified for that
thank you very very unfortunate way to
submit against the plan
we trust your judgment duncan
well we don't know yeah that's right
yeah you never you never know morris all
right
so i put that all late sorry kirsten
i just also say i think duncan's an
excellent choice because he's also been
part of woody nationally
ward which means he has an appreciation
for the woody and pegasus area as well
and so it gives him that very wide
perspective over his years of experience
don't get carried away dunking this one
pretty often
the issue there was that
all right i'll put it all those in favor
please say aye the country declare it
carried
item 6.4 pages 53-83
discretionary grant okay
to do with the first one reflections
community trust this is not
a new item it comes to the board
fairly regularly when i had a chat to
jim in regard to the agenda um
last week he asked me just to get some
figures
from the previous um requests for
funding from this group
so i just let you know that in 2016 it
was the first time they requested
funding from this board
and they were awarded two hundred
dollars 2017
the board declined their request
2018 they were awarded 292 dollars
in 2019 they were awarded
184 um
so i know that when the board
chairs were discussing criteria there
was some discussion
in regards to do the boards want to be
an annual funder for events um and it
was decided that each board needed to
make the decision for themselves so
there is no
nothing against it in the criteria it's
entirely up to the board
if they wish to continue to fund them
in regards to the north canterbury
indoor bales club this is
a new group that have applied to the
board
they are hosting indoors bowls
competition
and are requiring to hire a bigger hall
for the their function um
the tournament has grown from last year
so um which is quite nice and i think it
would be
quite quite apt for the board to maybe
give them a bit of funding
to grow the um image of rangiora
and southbrook um at this time in
covered
tainted times um and that's all i
can try and answer questions if anyone
has them just on the uh
the broad chairs meet from time to time
as you would see in reports
and we did discuss this issue and we
felt that it's best left to boards to
make their own determination but
the grants are really aimed at helping
groups set up and get established and
the chairs all felt and they didn't know
it was appropriate time to
make recommendations that where groups
were going to
all boards on more than on an annual
basis they should really be applying to
the council's
annual plan and not to this fund to the
board that was a view the chairs
had but we didn't take it any further as
kay said
right so poor question
yeah um it's sort of a question
[Music]
um we've got our community
and the council got their own page and i
was wondering whether
it would be appropriate because i see
they've got the lighting festival
advertised in that we actually offer um
for the council to advertise their
events and their
um local um
paige and the north carolina news in the
northern outlook which is
we get anyway so not not going to be an
actual extra cost to us
and um thus when we turn them down for
the actual
money the financial side of it which
would have a savings for to put to
another
community group um and also i'm a wee
bit concerned because
two hundred and forty dollars plus gst
are that amount
no no it's not the time to speak we
haven't got
okay yeah your question today was going
to be
uh would the council consider i presume
it was yeah
putting that in their head yeah um i
can't actually answer that because it
would depend on what else was being
advertised and whether there was space
in the allocated page without costing
any extra
kirsten um just a question to k
about 4.1 and 4.2 in the report
is this actually the view of the council
or the view of the trust
because that's not made absolutely clear
and i would question some of the
allegations in 4.1 and 4.2
uh this was i think part of the
letter that was included in the pack
that came to us
it's the way it's been expressed as fact
that concerns me i believe it's the
opinion of the trust
yes is that great i think you have to
take it it does
thank you and the second question is um
were you aware that there is a very
family-friendly trick-or-treating club
basically in rangiora that's been
running successfully
for many years and has about 4 000
followers
and seeks no funding and seeks no
funding and also
makes it very clear that elderly can put
up a sign no trick-or-treaters and they
discourage it thank you
right we've got any any direct question
we're almost debating it around the
circle without quite debating it
um if someone pretty poor
i'd like to move that we decline their
application
but we asked the council's communication
if they could actually submit
a um one or two ads in their own
council booklet towards this
situation so so
you're moving a receives a report
b the client knows
asks the council uh if they can
include the advertisement in their in
their
location and you're going to have a
just thinking are you going to so you
decline it and ask the council
yes you're saying all right and we're
second for that
by andy right look we'll deal with that
one first because it's a wee bit tricky
so
would you like to speak to would a would
take is grant
b this part b
we're taking it in parts yeah and i'm a
wee bit concerned that they
come up quite often and other boards of
funding as well
and i think if we can fund it with the
council or the advertisement they'll
probably get
better coverage and it won't cost them
the sport any money and we can save that
money for a major
a bit of a more wanting cause if you can
call it that
and so i think it'd be a win-win for
all scenarios and whatsoever and um
i would sort of um hesitate to
fund something particularly when half of
that money or
240 dollars is actually a thinking um
advertisement for the businesses where
um it's been suggested at quite a a good
letter
to the um the people that support them
would be
quite adequate as well but um but even
if we had to
um even they really what needed that
thank you we could probably put that in
our own council paper as well so
i think it's a win-win if we do it this
way okay
and did you expect
this does set a little bit of a
precedent because there are hundreds of
events in our
um district and where space is available
i'm sure that the council will be happy
to try and encourage
um putting in a space in in their paper
however it's not something we can offer
to every single event
it's often because there's some we're
trying to improve like at the moment
it's the covert response
we're trying to encourage people to get
out and actually be able to
recover from covert so therefore there
are some more event focus in our
communications
but that is not the purpose of the
council communication page
and that's the enc does that it's their
job
um so i'm just a little nervous about
the recommendation happy to ask the
question so that's why i'd be happy to
support it at this stage however i would
i would be very cautious
about this board um telling the council
how to run it
i don't think that's the intended
emotion i just think if that was the
council policy
then it is otherwise it's declined i
think it's quite straightforward
and speaking to the decline i i actually
agree with this one
it's it's a wonderful event for children
and it's a great event
but so are lots of others and and we
have um
an event funding package which we can
offer people through other other avenues
i've always been a bit cautious about
this one even though i've actually
spoken at the opening of it
um because of the religious connotations
and the fact that it's empty something
rather than just being pro children
having fun and all that sort of thing
it's a little bit awkward to support
something that's is deliberately set up
to be anti somewhat something else
other people's beliefs so um i would be
quite comfortable with declining this
application
um and offering the type of support if
we can if it's available that counselor
william suggests
do you think they should be directed to
other sources of funding with the
council
if as you said no well they weren't
aware of any other
that's their clear business to where
they go they've applied to us
we're here to deal with their
application i i thought you said that
there's other funds through available
through the council that they can apply
for
annual plans so maybe they could be
directed that way do you get my drift
okay um i know that
when i when this request went to the
woodend
um software board they
agreed to fund them for this year with a
letter written by me
saying this is the last year and they
should look at other funding sources
like the annual plan so i can do
something similar if the board
so yeah we'll add that to them yeah
all right write a reply paul
yeah um and my motion was actually
asking the council
um whether they could um submit it in
their thing
so that was the subject what have you
there's
today's one paper so that's the ad that
put them for a different community
um it's still a need for that type of
um similar thing but but they have had
things like that or not so
um but the motion was asking if they can
do it if they can't do it well that's
fine but
so that was the scenario there okay
we're clearing what we voted for a
receives it
and b has explained all those in favor
please say
contra declare carried the next part is
d
and e if someone prepared to move
that then north canterbury indoor bowls
were asking for five hundred dollars
moved by monique we grant them 500
we seconded for that segment by morris
do you wish to speak monique
morris
okay anyone else
i'll put that all those in favor please
say i country
carried item seven there's no
correspondence item eight
moved by myself seconded by duncan
report b
received all those in favor please say
aye contrary carried
items 9 0.1 right through to 9.23
and then the recommendation needs to
change and it should read
that the wrangler ashley community board
receives the information and items 9.1
and 9.2 that's a and b
that the public excluded minutes for
information
only be
received and the public
the end remain public excluded just to
cover that there because
that's this so i'll move that and we're
second to the kirsten
put that all those in favor please say
our country carried
members information exchange nick we'll
start with you
um let's keep wow i haven't i don't have
a lot but keep wrangler beautiful we did
we threw some trees
in the cemetery down over beyond
down near the use of cold stream road
there
and yeah which was cool we replaced them
um there's a close up with time bank
here
which i'm part of and that's really all
thank you
well not if you don't want to
with ecan greater college church
partnership
looking ahead 50 years the stadium
erie is going really really well we're
putting a roof on
[Music]
international joint promotions
association meeting
dpnr meeting marina if you're advising
me
in terms of lighting with appointed
cuban crowley to give us advice
on beautifying the lighting and
controlling europe
our
um
uh just one thing i attended the ranger
museum
meeting
how are they going maurice
it is useful when members report not
only say they've
been to a meeting but if there's
something here that should be shared
with the board it's appropriate to share
it this way just ask you the question
kirsten yes i've attended a lot of the
meetings that jones attended so i won't
repeat those
um ecan have also updated the canterbury
water management
strategy with a sort of a new focus and
this you can
give get more information on that on our
minutes if you wish
um an interesting meeting i met with
marie with customer services
and there'll be some more report coming
soon about service request progress
um because that's a been of great
interest to the board in the past
and they're progressing nicely on that
and um
the e-services type of work has been
pushed back a little bit with covert so
we've just they're going to update us on
that fairly soon
um we've also also hit a ssw meeting on
zoom which is our standard format now
unemployment is continuing to rise
pressure on food banks housing
is rising not unexpected
mental health issues obviously featuring
quite strongly
as well um in council news the pentecost
road stormwater has been brought forward
we pushed everything out with the
covered rate um
trying to trying to get the rate down to
1.5 and then the staff occasionally have
had to
actually speed some things up because
they've come further forward than we
thought they would
development in rangiora is progressing
very very quickly we're actually running
out of land
and that's going to be a significant
issue as part of the district plan
process
in the next 10 years um
the community facilities fee waiver
subcommittee was established
and there's an application process for
any community groups wanting to use
higher council facilities who are
struggling with the new hire fees which
was
discussed last term um and that could
you just go through green space to get
the application form
um shuttle reading really funding
obviously we've had a bit of a briefing
on all the money that the government's
allocated to us and that's coming to the
boards as you know next tuesday okay
we'll have
alluded to to the 6 pm sudden all boards
and we as jones said we've really
started digging into the high level look
at the ltp
the real key issues that are going to
face us for the budget
um and the staff are now working
furiously to try and get all those
budgets aligned
to bring us with an overall picture for
january
thanks matt thanks thanks um
andy thank you mr chair i
attended the um feature lighting uh
meeting as well with joan and paul
and it was uh constructive
[Music]
i'm concerned about how much it's going
to cost and
it may or may not come from but i'm
excited about
getting the concept design done for high
street and
for winning street and the bridge in
kaiapoi
so yeah it's actually it was really good
thank you because you're talking about
running out of land you think you should
rezone the
race course residential place
yeah i think it's been a busy busy time
for all councillors
and staff lately because of
what's happening with all the government
shovel ready projects and
funding no giving and we've actually
given some carrots
i don't know if it's a carrot or a bride
but one or the other
um but for this um for uh
renewa area one of the um the carrots
we've been given
um it looks like we may be able to
proceed with the fernside sirloin all
the way down john's road
to link up to the eastern sorry point of
order mr chair this is all public
excluded
or not it's nothing to do with this
meeting a council is reporting if he's
breaking council rules or not
that's up to that that it's not up to me
to make a ruling
[Music]
um
yeah um we have been uh been to a
meeting um
about the walkways and um
some of the river areas around
waimakariri
and um we're looking at um
enhancing some of the areas so
some of the rivers and i like the cam
river for example
and we've got to get maintenance crews
and everything to clean it out the
farmers and all that around the areas
have got to have fencing away from it
to keep your stock away from it so we're
we're gaining some excess waste these
rivers seem
eventually um there'll be some planting
and some
nice real walkways around the whole of
waimakariri and
it's going to be years to do um funding
will be a
big issue but we've got a reasonable
chunk of money and
so that's all going to enhance the whole
of um
winemaker and walkways and just
beautification generally
around the whole area so that will be
quite i think a challenging but a
worthwhile
project for that um to happen um
and this is not public excluded um
one of the major big things that's all
passed now is
we've had the uh probably our biggest
contract ever
um latin waimekureri for the
the roading side of things so um
we're carrying on with their existing
contractor it was
quite a tight um tendering system um
so um the mia and myself have got a
meeting coming to
um meet the managers and sort of um
push the um what we need to
talk to them about to improving the the
roading and the
potholes and shoulders and etcetera in
the
um the district and i
i think um cyclone are very respective
to
upgrading what they're intending to do
for us and um
and looking at it quite positively so um
um and for sierra saying in the
um i shouldn't i think i'll better
finish at that thank you
jason
um so it started off as a regular month
and i was going to have one meeting with
the north canterbury neighborhood
support
uh turned into two meetings because they
put me on a subcommittee
um so they're currently looking at
recruiting a manager for the
waimakariri district to grow their
network and develop their their
footprint around the community which
will be quite cool and quite exciting to
get on
and yes i'm just helping along with that
good thank you
sarah
um tomorrow night we have the first
gathering and meeting and greeting in
the
sort of guidelines in how the group's
going to run for the cycling
and walking steering group so that's
going to be
cool because i'm very interested in that
and we've had quite a few ideas we've
had
two people from this board with great
ideas
and ideas from outside of the board
so people are really interested in
creating better access not necessarily
cycle ways but actually
polishing up some of the areas that
people are walking through from a to b
school children adults um whatever
um and um yeah i'm looking forward to
being able to be a part
of being able to improve some of these
areas and create
new cycleways and walkways really great
thanks duncan um
just report that i did attend the henry
water liaison committee and it's quite
some time ago in july but i think they
face the same problems that imac do
regarding water in
the future water um also attended the
gary veer water opening
that's uh it was a very cool afternoon
but uh
very well done and i think it was uh not
that many turned up but it's been a good
project where the community has been
the user groups have been involved with
the council and heading in the direction
and um the only thing i
do regret is um the ringer show will not
be proceeding this year
obviously because of covered we can't
run it under presence conditions and
we're only
looking at a um reading crystal stars as
far as wondering what's going to be
happening in october
um but my understanding that's probably
the
fifth time there's been no show in here
154 history
yeah she sent me something along those
lines so we don't listen very often but
let's
just spread it thanks duncan murray
sorry yes how will that affect the
finances today
um because that would be quite a major
um funding for the show with with it
well public knowledge i i hope the
committee would say that we worked
pretty hard for a pretty
uh average return i i think we
hopefully the amp resilient enough and
it's probably
um you know it does own its grounds and
has to
hire out the facility for over the whole
year so we're doing something 364 days
of the rest of the year so
um well maybe a wee bit of a dip for us
um i don't think
we we hope you will weather the storm
yes is there anything the community
could do to
to help the situation there
were always a receptive people wishing
to hire our facilities are great
facilities
or a generous donation
we're not dating duncan's report here no
um
murray yeah well you you're probably
sorry to hear that the grey power
meeting for this month
has been cancelled because again you've
got problems because of this
virus and the other thing is that the
president of great power jim penecosta
myself
put a lot of work into our submissions
to canterbury health including a couple
of meetings
looks like we're going to have to do it
all again because the people we met with
have now left
so i'm waiting to find out who are going
to be appointed as
manager of planning and funding etc etc
so we can start all over again
and in the meantime i took uh member
lewis
out for a run around the town to have a
look at a couple of
access ways in the south of the town
where the locals
were raising questions about why they
couldn't have protected
pathways through their all cycle ways
mainly because
of their children getting from one side
of the town to the other
through the suburbs and there's another
one over the south brook creek and all
through
the dangerous landowner there isn't it
yeah yeah
steady yeah well actually i own some of
that
near there but mcgill one's trying to
buy it off me and i know what the reason
is
they want to stop that crash road
and i think don't think we should stop
that grass road because you've been down
there too mr chairman well that
board will be aware that's the area in
the route we've been talking about as a
potential
way to put cyclists and things down here
away from the main road
and someone's some image has built a
bridge over the creek which is a bit
hair-raising and some of the people are
complaining about that
i didn't feel a bit serious making sure
i didn't
right
yes i just forgot to mention that
at long last we have um now got the
designation for the ring your airfield
has been approved good
that's that's great it's taken years of
getting there
thank you joan right item 11 there are
no current consultation
projects item 12 is
balances no media items
although on the media items i have been
run by
junos today about the
race course and i i played it very low
key i said i wasn't in a position really
to comment at the moment
the board hasn't made a final
determination we know what we're going
to determine but that's beside the point
and we just didn't want put the board in
any sort of position there before we've
formally discussed it
but the opposition is really substantial
from what i'm gathering and
the mayor and i received or the mayor
really received and invited me to join
him
five thousand in the two to five
thousand signatories on the two
petitions
opposing it so
in front of the paper
good so yeah yeah so
that's happening there
god the paper isn't that up right
no questions no urgent general business
so we we now move into workshop mode
and i welcome kitchen solid
waste asset manager to
to join us getty welcome
homes welcome exactly
yeah yeah i did bring some show-and-tell
handouts
um someone else forgot those around
because presume you've all read the memo
well release is handing those out um
my memo alerts you to the fact that we
are going to be sending some letters out
to the public next week i've just been
informed that
um the reach media will have received
their packs tomorrow for
delivering litter boxes
and the letters will be
starting being posted to the addressed
properties
next week as